so i've been sent this definite integral
problem and it seemed as good as any and
i think the key with this is just to see
a lot of examples so let's do it so
let's see this definite integral
is from
pi
over 2
to pi
of minus
cosine
squared of x
times sine of x
dx
so before we just chug through the math
and do the antiderivatives and use the
fundamental theorem of calculus to
evaluate the definite integral let's
think about what we're even doing so
i've graphed this function right here
minus cosine squared of x times sine of
x and what we care about we're finding
the definite integral between
pi over 2 which is roughly here let me
see if i can make this a little bit
bigger
so between pi over 2 which is right
there and between pi
so the definite integral of this
function between here and here is
essentially the area
of the curve between the curve and the
x-axis and since the curve is below the
x-axis here this area is going to be a
negative number so that gives us
immediately an intuition we should be
getting a negative number when we
evaluate this and just to prove this is
actually typed it in up here
so let's now evaluate this definite
integral
now i'll rearrange some of the terms
here just to make it a little bit easier
to read but the way i always think about
it is well if you have a cosine and a
sine
the cosine is squared so all these crazy
things are happening to it so
it seems like i could use substitution
or the reverse chain rule somehow here
and what was the chain rule the chain
rule said if i took the derivative
of
of f of
g of x
that this is equal to
f prime
of g of x
times g prime of x
that might completely confuse you but i
just wrote that here because oh we could
say well what if g of x
is cosine of x f prime of g of x is the
cosine of x squared and then the
derivative of g of x or the derivative
of cosine of x is sine of x well it's
actually minus sine of x and we have a
minus sign here so that works out well
too if this confuses you ignore it
essentially we're going to do the same
thing but we're going to do it with
substitution so let me do it with
substitution
let me erase this
if this confuses people
i want to do it however it is least
confusing to you
okay let me erase that actually let me
do it with substitution just because
the way i was just doing is kind of my
shortcut when i'm you know
back in the day when i was a mathlete
but
it's good to be able to do it with
substitution and helps you from making
careless mistakes let me rewrite this
first of all this is the same thing as
the integral from pi over 2
to pi
of
cosine
squared of x actually let me
let me write that as cosine of x squared
same thing right
times
minus sine of x
minus sine of x dx
and now it should be a little clearer to
you what's the derivative of cosine of x
it's minus sine of x so i have a
function and it's being squared and have
its derivative
so i can figure out its antiderivative
by using substitution or the reverse
chain rule so let's make the
substitution
u is equal to
cosine of x how did i know to substitute
u is equal to cosine of x well because i
say well the derivative of this function
is here so when i find d u this whole
thing is going to end up being du and
let's let me show that to you so what is
du dx
du
dx
is equal to minus sine of x
that hopefully we've learned already so
what is d u
if we multiply both sides by the
differential d of x we get d u is equal
to minus
sine of x
dx
so if we look at this original the
original equation
this right here we just showed is equal
to d u
and this right here is what cosine of x
is u that was our original substitution
so we have u squared
u squared
so now let's take the integral
and i will arbitrarily switch colors
and now this is a very important thing
if you're going to do substitution if
we're going to say u is equal to cosine
of x we're going to have to actually
make the substitution on the boundaries
or we could do the substitution reverse
the substitution and then evaluate the
boundaries but let's do that so if this
is going from x is equal to pi over 2
to pi what is it what is u going from
well when x is equal to pi over 2 u is
equal to cosine of pi over 2
cosine of pi over 2 right because u is
just cosine of x
and then when x is pi
u is going to be cosine of pi
cosine of pi
and now the the fun part cosine of x
squared well that's just the same thing
as u squared
and minus sine
of x dx that's the same thing as d u
did that here
d u
so this is equal to this is a pretty
straight forward and i'm just going to
rewrite it what's cosine of pi cosine of
pi is minus one
cosine of pi over two well that's zero
so we have the integral from u is equal
to 0 to u is equal to negative 1 of u
squared d u and now this
seems like a simple problem
so this is equal to the antiderivative
of u squared
which is fairly straightforward u cubed
over 3
right you could just take the derivative
of this you get this all i did is i
increased this exponent to get the third
and then i divided by that exponent
and we're gonna have to evaluate it at
minus one and subtract from that it
evaluated at zero
and so this is equal to
minus one to the third over three minus
0 over 3 and so this is equal to minus
1 3.
and we are done and if we look at this
area
from our original graph what we just
solved is we said the area of the curve
between here and here
is minus one third
or if you wanted the absolute area
because you can't really have a negative
area it's one-third but we know it's
negative because this curve is below the
x-axis here and that looks about right
that looks like about one-third i mean
if this is if this cube right here is
one then that looks about one-third so
this is uh the intuition all works out
at least so hopefully you found that
vaguely useful
and actually i just wanna
actually let me let me since we have a
little bit of time hopefully you
understood this and if you did don't
worry about what i'm going to do now but
i want to show you how i tend to do it
where i just think of it as the reverse
chain rule
and it's a little bit quicker sometimes
but it's really the same thing as what
we just did with substitution so if we
erase all of this
all of this
and so if we have this integral right
here
what i do is i say well i have cosine of
x squared
let me take this minus well i could use
this one i have cosine of x squared and
then i have minus sine of x
this
is the derivative of this
since the derivatives here i can just
treat this whole thing
like an x term
so this is the same thing
so the anti-derivative is
cosine
of x
to the third
over three
and i evaluated at pi
and pi over 2 and remember how did i do
this what allowed me to treat this
cosine of x just like an x or like a u
when i did with the substitution well i
had his derivative sitting right here
minus sine of x so that's what gave me
the license to just take the
antiderivative pretend like this cosine
of x is just an x it's just a a u you
could even say and just say take it x
exponent raise it by one and divide it
by three and then evaluate it from pi to
pi over two
so this is equal to cosine
of pi
cubed over 3
minus cosine of pi over 2
cubed over 3.
this is minus 1 to the third so this is
equal to minus one-third minus this is
zero so we get the same answer i just
wanted to show you that it's exactly the
same with substitution it's just i
didn't formally do the substitution but
it's the exact same thing anyway hope
you found that helpful